And now it's to you, Scoutmaster.
Well, in this podcast I had planned to talk about ignorance and apathy.
Yeah, I had planned on it, but I really don't know all that much about it
And I don't really care all that much about it either.
Oh my,
Hey, this is podcast number 64..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Our March newsletter giveaway winner, I'm proud to announce, is Chris Hammey.
Chris is a committee member for Troop 154 in Sylvania, Ohio,
And Chris was randomly drawn from all those who provided the correct answer to this month's trivia question.
And Chris will receive a package from E-Lite.
E-Lite is an electrolyte replacement product, a concentrate that you use and put right in your water bottle.
Pretty cool product
Heard from a lot of people this week. so let's get right to the emails and the messages.
Warren had this to say:
I'm a leader in a Cub Scout pack, which is different than a Boy Scout troop,
but we constantly have the issue of people deciding to go on a trip or activity at the last moment.
We do our best to accommodate, but it seems to be the same people every time,
No matter how many times we announce it at a pack meeting or we put it on the website, put it in a newsletter
and email the date of the event and the deadline. we still get requests days after the deadline has passed.
Basically, it's the same story.
I didn't know the deadline had passed,
My husband or wife told me we could still sign up.
We forgot to sign up and Johnny really wants to go.
I mean, it's such a pain, but we do it for the boys and we always try to accommodate.
Unfortunately, we can't always make the adjustments at the last minute.
If you can figure this one out, Clark, you should be able to earn a badge.
Warren, it's probably something that we're never going to figure out.
It's just one of those things.
And now we all know that none of us are alone.
This happens everywhere, all the time.
Oh well,
From Trip 2379, Tracy Lucas wrote in. she says this:
My Scoutmaster, husband Dave and I continue to enjoy your podcast
and never fail to bring away something valuable each week.
Thank you again for your words of encouragement
and for putting in the countless hours to help us all out.
Well, I certainly appreciate you getting in touch, Tracy,
and I've been going back and forth with Tracy and Dave through the emails,
Just working on some of the stuff going on with the troop there
And it looks like things are going well.
So Godspeed to both of you.
First of all, this comes from Kyle P Ryle.
I think I got that right, Kyle P Ryle, Very poetic.
First off, a big fan of your podcast.
I'm fairly new to scouting and the podcast scene
and I'm wondering what microphone you use,
as I really like the quality of the sound you produce.
Any info would be appreciated. Thanks,
Kyle is a Scoutmaster in troop 169 in Barnum, Minnesota.
Well, Kyle, I sent you the tech information on the microphone,
but of course you have to have a dulcet
and well-seasoned voice, just like mine.
All right, Yeah, it is mostly the microphone,
but I appreciate you getting in touch.
I heard from Tom Gillard down in Tennessee again.
He says I'm still trying to keep myself quiet at a PLC.
We're trying to go through guided discovery.
let the boys plan a trip to Rocky Mountain National Park this summer,
but it is truly painful.
The first meeting went pretty well
and they defined the important pieces of the trip,
and last night, when they started putting their names on the administration slots
and prioritizing things, there was a lot of dead space.
What would have taken the adults? maybe 30 minutes,
took them an hour and a half.
Well, yeah, I know It's crazy at the time,
but that's the learning process.
That's the process. That's what we want to have happen.
I'll tell you something:
When you're experiencing something like Tom is experiencing
a little bit of frustration-
boys doing stuff and it takes a whole lot longer than adults-
that's a good indication that you have a scout-run troop
and that you're on point with the program.
But it's good to hear from you again, Tom.
James Chaplin wrote in to say:
wow, fantastic new web page
and it looks like you've added a new workload to try and keep it updated.
Thanks for doing this. from a rookie scoutmaster,
only 10 years.
Well, you're a little bit more than a rookie there, James.
On the high adventure pages, we really need this-
a shared resource for ideas other than the big three
national high adventure bases.
But you got your work cut out for you.
I see a pretty empty map
And then James gives me some suggestions.
James, I have been in touch with those places
and I hope to hear from them soon.
James goes on to say:
if every scouter shares their ideas,
it may become one awesome feature to your web page and blog.
Good luck with it.
If you haven't visited the new web page and blog,
it's ScoutmasterCG,
Scoutmaster, the letter C, the letter G,
all one word: com, ScoutmasterCGcom.
Do you get that? All right,
And we do have a high adventure resources page
that we're putting together
And I have solicited different high adventure programs
throughout the country to send me a profile
of their program and contact information
and pictures and things like that.
Now, if you've participated in one of the high adventure programs
outside of Fillmont or Seabase or Northern Tier-
I mean those three programs- they get a lot of press,
They're easy to find out information about,
But there are lots of programs all over the country
that are ones that might be more accessible, cost-wise
and distance-wise and planning-wise
to you and your scouts,
And I'm pretty sure that everybody needs to go
on a high adventure trip at least once
while they're involved with scouts.
So you can get in touch at ScoutmasterCGcom
and let me know about the high adventure places
and experiences that we don't have featured there yet.
Larry Geiger got in touch and said this:
Good podcast, Clark,
I really like the new blog
and I agree with you about Scoutmaster conferences.
Larry went on to list a lot of good information
about Scoutmaster conferences
that I'm not going to try and read out right now,
but go ahead and go to ScoutmasterCGcom.
You'll see the comment from Larry there.
He always has great stuff to offer.
Thanks for being in touch again, Larry.
Well, this time around
we're going to talk in Scoutmastership,
in seven minutes or less,
how to protect the quality of the scouting program.
That's right.
We're finally going to get down to it
and tell you just exactly how to do it.
And then we have an email question that came in
that is related to the subject
And that will be enough for this podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
Scouting is a nationwide movement
of about 2.8 million youth
and 1.3 million adults,
And the whole thing is all written down.
It's been around for a century
and it's defined in policies and procedures
and manuals and training
and all kinds of good resources that are out there.
It's not really subject to an individual's understanding
or the way that they would like to invent it
or reinvent it or apply it.
There's some pretty cut and dried stuff,
And the reason that it's cut and dried
is because it works.
I liken this to getting some kind of
new electronic gadget or power tool
or something like that.
Everybody's probably done that.
You know we send away for it
and we get it in the mail,
or we go to the store and we pick it up
And if you're like me,
the first thing you want to do is unwrap that new toy
and start playing with it.
You know we plug it in, power it up
and forge ahead right,
And then when something doesn't work
like we think it should,
we kind of get frustrated
and we assume one or two things.
We assume that the toy is broken
and maybe we just throw it back in the box
and forget about it,
Or we invent some kind of ingenious workaround
to avoid the supposed flaw in the tool
or the toy or the gadget
And especially the kind of personality
that becomes a scout leader,
Because we've. you know
it takes a bit of an ego.
It takes some self-assurance and confidence.
It takes somebody who is going to forge ahead
and who is going to make things happen.
You know, back to the toy.
after we've grown dissatisfied
with the way that it works and everything,
as a last resort we might fish the manual
that came along with it out of the trash
and start reading impatiently.
Are you following me here?
Has this happened to you.
It's happened to me.
We might read that manual kind of impatiently
after we get through the seven different languages
and all the warnings and everything like that
and get to the point where they start talking about
how to use the thing
and we may eventually find an answer
to the problem that we were having with it.
We may find out: oh well, you know,
you have to do this before you do this,
Or you have to charge it up for 12 hours,
Or oh, it could be any one of a hundred things.
And that might even make us more disgruntled
or more upset with the whole thing
than we were when we first found out
that it didn't work the way that we had hoped it worked.
And it can cause a real disconnect in our thinking
because we've got our new toy
and it doesn't work the way that we think it should work.
You know it works the way it was designed to work,
but not necessarily the way we think it should work.
So you know we're going to either take it back
and get our money back,
or we're sheepishly going to admit
that our first assumptions weren't exactly correct
and now we will make an uneasy peace
with our new toy or tool
and it will go to work for us.
So you know where I'm going with this right,
Because scouting is a lot like this.
It's something that we come to and we think:
well, you know, if we were scouts when we were youth,
we have a set of assumptions based on our experiences
that we're going to work with.
If we volunteer to become scouts as adults,
you know our son gets involved
and then you volunteer to become a scout as an adult
And of course you don't want to look
as though you don't know anything.
So you make some assumptions and you move on
and you've heard different things
about Scoutmasters and scouts
and the way it's supposed to work,
just in the general culture.
And when things don't work
the way that we think they ought to work,
we get a little disgruntled
and we might start changing things
and trying to fix things that don't need fixing.
And as a last resort, we fish out the manual
and we read and we find out what to do
to make things work properly.
I'll give you an example.
Let's take a look at two Scout requirements
For the Scout badge. number 7 says:
you understand and agree to live by
the Scout oath or promise
the Scout law, the motto and slogan in the outdoor code.
That's what it says
For the tenderfoot rank. the same number,
number 7, says: repeat from memory
and explain in your own words
the Scout oath, law, motto and slogan.
Now a new Scout needs to understand
and agree to live by the basic tenets of Scouting,
while the Scout challenging the tenderfoot rank
has to have some of these things memorized
and he needs to be able to explain them in his own words.
How many of you have required a new Scout
to get the Scout badge,
to have the Scout oath and law memorized?
Is your hand up? Mine is too.
I've done that in the past.
I know I used to do that.
but I carefully read the requirement
for some reason at one point
and then I compared it with the tenderfoot one
and, hey, I was doing something wrong
After years and years. I was doing something wrong
because it wasn't up to me to redefine the clear words
in that Scout rank requirement to mean:
oh yeah, well, you should have this memorized.
If I make it more difficult
and I make it more rigorous,
then my Scouts will be better,
because I will have him memorize this
and then he'll have it memorized
by the time he becomes a tenderfoot.
What could be wrong with that,
And maybe you know, in 88% of instances
in the Scouts that you're dealing with,
it's not going to be a big deal,
but then there's going to be those that don't get it.
you know that don't memorize well
and they need a little bit of time
before they're going to be able to do that
and they get a little discouraged
about the Scout badge
and then they say goodbye to you.
I started reading requirements and policies
with a lot of care,
and I was especially conscious of things
that challenged my preconceptions,
and then the next step was getting myself in line
with what I had read
and making sure that I was going according
to policy and procedure-
not to be, you know, legalistic and not to,
but, because I found this out,
Scouting and the quality of skills and advancement
and those types of questions
cause us a lot of trouble as leaders,
just in general.
I get lots of emails about them-
and we're going to hear one of those in a moment,
and that's why I'm prefacing it
with this little discussion-
and sometimes we make decisions
and we set our course on bad directions,
and so we need to make some adjustments
once in a while
When we adhere to the policies
and procedures of scouting.
when we learn them and things,
what we find is that scouting protects itself,
The program protects itself,
The quality of the program
protects itself
and we don't have to become the quality police.
When we learn about the way
the uniform is supposed to be worn
and when we learn about the way advancement works
and we learn how all this is supposed to happen,
it all protects itself
and it has done for the past century.
thank you very much.
You know we don't have to dive in
and try and fix things that don't need to be fixed
and that, I am of the increasing belief,
is the solution to 99.9%
of the difficulties, problems
and things like that
that adults encounter
as they go through their work
as scout volunteers.
In part, the takeaway from this
is that we need to challenge
our preconceptions of things,
the things that we are absolutely sure that we know-
and make sure that we reconcile them
to the way that the program is set up
and written and administered.
It's very, very important
and it's one of the greatest things
that we can do as a scout volunteer,
because once we do that,
we've aligned all of the way
that we're doing things
with the way that really works best.
Like I said, we've had a century
of experience with this.
That century has proven out
in countless situations all over the country
what works and what doesn't,
and it's a real good idea
for us to base our program
and our activity and our leadership
on those things that have
a good, proven track record
and that we know will work.
E-mail- that is folks,
And here's an answer
to one of your e-mails.
This e-mail comes from Brian and he says this:
I really enjoy the site and look forward
to each new episode of the podcast.
I've left comments on the blog
and a positive review on the podcast,
but this time I have a question for you,
if you're able to answer it.
May an advancement chair or scoutmaster reject
a blue card for a merit badge
if they suspect a scout has not completed
the requirements, even if it has been
signed by a registered merit badge counselor,
How would you handle that situation
If there was
considerable doubt in your mind that a scout
completed the requirements and doubt that the counselor
had properly taught the material?
Brian goes on to say: my opinion is
to take the counselor at his
or her word and award the boy with the achievement,
but in the future either provide
training to the counselor or not use them.
There are others
in the troop, however, that don't feel comfortable
awarding boys the badges and have chosen
to deny submitting the achievement.
I appreciate your perspective
and experience. What are your thoughts on this situation?
I want to make sure the boys are rewarded
for their efforts. I don't want to be
in the business of double checking merit badge counselors,
but of course I want to maintain the
quality and significance of the program.
I'd appreciate any thoughts. Keep up the good work.
It's really helpful and inspiring.
And thanks, Brian, for getting
in touch. And I think,
based on what we just
heard in Scout Mastership in
seven minutes or less, the answer to this is going to be
pretty easy. You
describe in your email a very
common concern for many Scouts
and a question that comes up again and again
and again and again: Quality of achievement
work and the quality of
skills and the quality of advancement.
From one perspective, we should be concerned
that Scouts learn important skills, and I
don't want to appear cavalier or dismissive
of the idea that there are many things
a Scout needs to know and needs to know
well. But some Scouts
appoint themselves as quality control officers
and they cause a lot more problems than they
solve. To answer your first
question, there is
no question that any merit badge
application signed by a registered counselor
is a done deal.
A Scout presenting a completed application
has it checked, not for the
quality of his skills or the completeness
of the information that he's learned,
but just has it checked
in and recorded,
And this isn't subject to review
or judgment from anyone. The counselor
has the absolute last word.
This also applies to signatures
in a Scout handbook for badges of rank.
The horse is out of the barn, the cat is out
of the bag, the toothpaste is out of the tube,
the die is cast. we award
the badge. End
of story. Is that clear?
So
a signed blue card.
there's no questioning, there's no judging.
we award the badge.
So we need to tell the folks in your
troop, Brian, that there is absolutely
no basis in policy or procedure
for them to deny a Scout his
achievement. They need to find the certificates
they denied him, they need to submit
them right away and
if they're not willing to do so, they need
to go find something else to do
where they can be useful in their community
instead of messing up the
Scout program. Now, that's
strong words, but I feel pretty passionate
about this. What happens if
we do suspect that a Scout did not complete
the work or that the counselor was
not rigorous enough in their evaluation
of a merit badge?
Well, we certainly don't go to the Scout
and make him suffer.
We don't seek to find this
out from the Scout in
other than the most casual way,
Because it's absolutely not his
fault. if things didn't work well,
It is the fault of the counselor.
Now, who registers merit badge
counselors in your council
and district? Is it the troop that does this?
Well, you might accept some
applications, you might forward them to somebody,
but usually it's the district advancement
chairman or the district advancement committee,
in some cases the council advancement
committee. So
what happens if we
have a difficulty with a merit badge counselor?
There's
a couple of approaches. One would be to speak
directly with the counselor, but
my preferred approach is
to talk to the folks on your
council
or district advancement committee
And say: look, you know,
I was just not too sure about this. I don't
want to make a whole lot of waves. I know
that the counselor is a volunteer, just like
I am, and they're trying to do their best.
but you know, we asked some questions
and it seemed that
we were probably short-cutting a couple
of things on that particular merit badge
And then let
them follow it up. it goes off
of your plate onto theirs.
it's never an issue again. Just leave
it be. You have more important
things to do. Merit badge counselors
are volunteers, just like us. they share
our ideals and goals.
a very, very few may get
misinformed or misdirected, but they are
all working in what they see
as the best interest of
each individual scout that they're working with.
Let's also remember
that a merit badge, put in
perspective, is a bit of cloth that
memorializes a scout's achievement in
exploring a given subject and demonstrating
some skill and understanding in
some of the basics of that subject.
It's not a license, it's not
a diploma, it's not a certificate
of the completion of a
complicated technical course.
It's a merit badge. It's unique.
It's something that
scouting has that nobody else has.
The way we maintain the quality and significance
of scouting is by following
the policies and procedures that were given
as they are written.
It's very, very important And when
we do this, scouting takes care of itself.
The quality of things take care of
itself. You know
the folks that we're working along
with the merit badge counselors, the counselors
at summer camp. you know our fellow
leaders and
all these wonderful people who are dedicating
themselves to
the betterment of our scouts.
We need to work along with them.
We need to understand that not everybody
is going to be hitting on all eight cylinders
every single day, And we need
to have a little bit of serendipity
and acceptance with some of
these things and know how to fix them
when they are truly out of line.
So I hope that helps Brian
and everybody else.
I hope that sheds a little light on the subject
And I'm interested to hear your opinions and your
elaborations. and
whether you agree with me or not,
Do get in touch And you're going to find out how to do that
in just a moment.
Music.
Thanks for listening to another edition of
the Scoutmaster podcast.
Let me take a moment to mark the passing
of a man most of you don't know,
But you'd recognize him, though, for the warm smile
and the ready friendship
familiar to anyone involved in scouting.
We all know at least one person
like him, because he was
that guy.
You know what I mean: The guy who you saw
at every meeting, at every event.
The guy who was always ready to roll up
his sleeves and got to work,
And the guy who got things done.
Scouting's blessed
with thousands of men like him.
Every district, every council
has at least some one,
But more often
you know several of these guys and gals.
they have to
have them, otherwise the
Zora district just wouldn't exist.
This week, Bill
Taylor, our council president here in
Chester County, came to the end of the
trail. He's gone home and we'll miss him.
We keep on moving, though,
doing the work that he devoted himself to
because he'd have it no other way.
And peace to you, Bill,
Peace to yours,
Music.
Well, thanks for
listening once again, and here's how to keep
in touch. You can read the Scoutmaster
blog at ScoutmasterCGcom.
That's
ScoutmasterCGcom.
And
while you're there, you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster
newsletter, which is a monthly digest of
the Scoutmaster blog and podcast, with some
great scouting resources around a
monthly theme, And every newsletter
includes a giveaway from one of our affiliate
sponsors,
Music.
You can subscribe to the
Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes and, when
you do, feel free to leave a comment
or a review or a rating,
You can call and involve
yourself in the Scoutmaster podcast.
You can be our participant
in the Scoutmaster podcast by calling
484-734-0002..
You'll hear a voicemail announcement
by yours truly, and then you can
leave a comment or a question that will be
included in the Scoutmaster podcast.
How about that?
You can follow us at ScoutmasterBlog on
Facebook and ScoutmasterCG on Twitter,
and you can email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at ClarkGreen at
gmailcom. That's
C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N
at gmailcom.
Music.
Now I need to take a moment
and say that the Scoutmaster blog and the
Scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America. Hey, it's just
me, That's right,
Talking into a microphone, trying to lend
a hand to Scout leaders and perhaps have
a little bit of fun along the way.
Speaking of fun, here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir?
Until next time.
Thank you.